Gav: We're trying to film
something that is quite rare,
but incredibly dangerous
to a firefighter,
and it's called a backdraft.
- Man: Open it up.
- Backdraft initiated.
Dan:
Oh, it's like a dragon.
- Whoa!
God!
Probably one of the most
terrifying videos
that I've shot.
'Cause it leads you
to imagine,
you know, what could
happen in real life.
Just to see smoke coming
out of there one second.
The next second,
there's huge explosion.
We once again put the Phantom
in an incredibly
dangerous position.
Whoa!
( both sigh )
We should really
stop doing that.
But once again, it survived.
Dan: We did have
some marshmallows
that seemed to be a bit cooked,
but the Phantom was okay.
One of the most
interesting shots, I thought.
was when all the marshmallows,
they all got knocked
just from the force
of the explosion.
So it could easily blow you
off your feet.
Dan:
It was, like, surprising.
I feel like a lot of the time
when we're doing
an intro to a video,
we're stood somewhere
quite nice and comfortable
and then we go on
to do the experiment.
That was the most stressful
intro I've ever been a part of.
Not gonna lie, in the intro
I was trying to be all
casual and cool.
Like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
Like, trying to make a gag
about how it was cold outside.
I was like,
"I've gotta get out of here."
It was just so hot.
Quite cold outside,
so I'm going to warm
myself up a little bit.
I think
I'm warm enough, actually.
- All right.
Oh, it's pretty hot!
- Let's head outside.
I came out,
and I was just like,
"Holy cow."
Yeah, I had the cameras roll
right after we got of there
so we could talk about
what it was like
to be inside a burning room
with a rollover on the ceiling.
Okay, so we just finished
the intro to part one.
I mean, if you're gonna
learn to do an intro
in one take or two takes,
I feel like
- that's the best way to do it.
- We knelt down between takes
just 'cause it was
getting so hot
and stood back up
to do the second take.
But obviously you sort of
retain a lot of the heat
- that you had
in the first take.
- Yeah.
And the end
of the second take,
I felt like
the last ten seconds of that
just got so hot.
The air I was breathing
was hot.
My shoulder--
my left shoulder boiling.
Dan: And my shoulder
is still warm.
Like, it's still hot.
I felt your shoulder here.
This part is still warm.
My actual like skin
through all those layers
is still, like, hot.
That was an experience.
All right, here's one
of our wide shots.
It sort of had
the boomiest wide that we had.
Um, and using your very
technical marshmallow sticks,
we can figure out the speed
of this backdraft
at its fastest.
Yeah, so I think
I'll start timing
- past this one to this one.
- Marshmallow one.
Gav:
Okay, that many.
- Dan: To there.
- Let's stop it there.
So at our shooting
frame rate of 1,000,
it went from here to here
in 145 frames.
That's five feet.
The speed was 35 feet
per second.
- So that's 23 miles an hour.
- Yeah.
Which is sort of
Olympic sprinter speeds.
You have to be literally
an Olympic sprinter.
It would be
a real dramatic scene
running in front
of a backdraft.
You'd have to already be
at full tilt
going that way at this point
to not get hit by that.
And then it sort of slows down
as it gets further along.
I'd say
that's the fastest point
that we can measure on this.
Dan: It's really busting out
of there, though, still.
So you've seen it in action,
but to find out more
about what causes a backdraft,
we spoke to Fire Chief Ken,
who's... there.
There he is, yeah.
We're here
with Chief Ken Bailey
from Travis County
Fire Rescue.
- Good to see you guys.
- Hello.
- That was a good handshake.
- That's a solid handshake.
That is a solid handshake, yeah.
So, what exactly is a backdraft
and how does it work?
So, a backdraft is where
all the contents
are started on fire,
and then all the oxygen
is consumed
in a sealed container.
What ends up happening
is we reintroduce oxygen
and we have a rapid
explosion of the gases
which were the products
of combustion.
And how often
would that happen
in normal firefighting?
You know, most people go
a career without seeing it.
- So it's a very rare
occurrence.
- Right.
- But a very sudden
and dangerous one.
- Exactly.
I heard somewhere
that you have less time
to get out
of a house fire now.
So, back when our parents
had furnishings in the house,
it was probably made
of cotton or wool,
and those will only
let off so much heat over
a certain period of time.
The heat release rate
on those were different.
And the products
that we buy today,
they're cheaper,
they're Styrofoam.
Look at it as solid fuel.
And so the heat release rate
is much, much faster on that.
It very quickly
consumes the oxygen.
If the home was sealed,
and then
the fire department shows up,
they open the door,
and we have that
introduction of oxygen
in that sealed compartment,
it gives us the challenge
of the potential backdraft.
I was just blown away
when we were in there
doing our intro
just how hot you still feel
through all the gear.
- Dan: I'm still
cooling off now.
- Gav: Yeah.
It was like half an hour ago.
I'm, like, still warm.
And with, like, a beard,
which I wouldn't have
- if I was a firefighter.
- Non-regulation.
The seal on my mask
was letting in hot air, too.
So that was-- I've got--
think I'm gonna shave this off
before we go back in.
Next time you come back,
you should just shave,
like, a strip
for the gas mask.
So, say I'm just
a person in the house,
my house has caught fire,
I called the fire department.
Is there any state
that I can leave my house
that's safer from backdrafts
or shall I just get
the hell out of there?
Getting out of the house
is the most important.
We would much rather
you burn your house down
and save your life
than try to stay with it
or delay 911 by--
That's one
of the problems we have,
is people will--
will think,
"Hey, we can handle
this situation."
And then that delays
a call to 911,
and then when we get there,
it's a much larger fire
than it needed to be.
So if you're in a room
with all locked doors
and there's a fire door,
and there's a window,
and there's a fire,
how should you get out?
How's the best way
to get out safely?
So if you're in
an interior corridor
and you're trying to make it
through the fire area,
the area that's involved,
and you have the choice
between that and a window,
I'd choose the window
before the other.
All it takes
is a couple of breaths
of that carbon monoxide
and hydrogen cyanide
and some of the other
products of combustion,
and your chances are
that you won't
make it to the door.
We tried to contact
a lot of people
to get this simulated
and you guys are one
of the very few people
who said that you'd be up
to recreate a backdraft.
And you actually did it,
so we're extremely grateful
that you could help us out
- and make this video with us.
- Yeah, very much, Ken.
- That was really informative.
- Thank you. It was our honor.
- Also scary, as well.
- We appreciate it.
All right, back to you,
Gav and Dan.
Thanks, us.
Now, very few people
will come into contact
with a real, full-sized
backdraft like that.
- Thank goodness.
- But there is a much smaller
version of a backdraft
that people might be
familiar with.
So why don't we go outside
and do an experiment?
- All right.
You know, Dan, I'm really glad
we film this in winter.
Yeah, it's nice, isn't it?
Good barbecue weather.
Nice time for a barbie.
- Yeah.
- So, using what we've learned,
you think you can create
a mini backdraft with this?
- I think so.
- All right.
I'll set the scene.
It's the summer.
It's not raining.
Got a nice, hot barbecue.
It's been on for awhile.
Hot coals.
And we got our chicken.
It's gonna be covered in oil,
'cause that's how
you cook chicken, isn't it?
If I just introduce the fuel--
so this is like the wood
in the back of the container.
I'll just pop that
on the thing.
- Oh, you can tell
it's already hot.
- Yeah, it's already hot.
- Immediately lit up.
- Then I close this down,
shut the flames down,
and then when
I reintroduce the oxygen...
it should pop out.
- Very nice.
- See that?
That was great.
- Dan: Just medium chicken.
- Medium chicken.
Dan: Oh, you see all the smoke
going in? Do you see that?
- Gav: You see it rush out.
- And that's that same pattern.
Gav: It's a similar effect.
The smoke's kind of getting
sucked back around.
Dan: Yeah. That oxygen just
rushes in and then boom.
Gav: And then it just ignites
all the-- the smoke, really.
- Dan: Yeah.
- A little mushroom cloud
for a second there.
Look at that.
Dan: It's sucking all
the smoke and fire out.
Gav: Like a tabletop nuke.
Dan: Not what you wanna see
on a barbecue, really.
Gav: Conditions
are becoming good.
Dan: Oh, yeah, you see all
the oxygen rushing in
and then allowing the fuel
to burn again.
Gav: Reignite.
Dan: It's funny how that fire,
it had all gone out
'cause it had been
starved of oxygen.
Gav: Yeah, you can't really
think about fire
that's gone out
as being out, really.
Dan: No. That's what's
dangerous about it.
So that was sort of
a medium backdraft.
This time I'm gonna
skip the chicken out
and just pretend
I'm some sort of Muppet
who's never used
a barbecue before.
"Oh, looks like
it's going out!"
So I'll put
a bunch of fuel on it,
which is this oil here.
You got a message
for anyone watching at home?
Uh, probably just,
"Don't do it"?
Kids, just don't--
don't do it.
Don't try at home.
- Oh, it's gonna--
- I know.
- I'll cover that up.
- Gonna be colossal.
- Are you nervous?
- Nah, I'll be all right.
- All right.
- Tell me when you're ready.
- Ready.
- Here we go.
Whoa. Potentially delicious.
Dan: "Po-tench."
Gav: All right, this is
some serious business.
Dan: All right.
Full-- just an oil meal.
Just eating some oil.
- Ooh! Oh, that--
- Gav: Whoa, look at that.
That was significantly bigger.
Dan: I've just disappeared
behind a waft
of pure fire there.
Gav: Where have you gone?
Look at that.
It's dragon smoke.
- Dan: I wonder if
the prawns are done.
- It looks really cool.
Dan: 'Cause the lid is round,
a perfect ball of smoke
- and fire comes out.
- Yeah.
Dangerously beautiful
that one.
Dan: Yep. Very singe-y.
Gav: It's lingering
on your head.
That's your "I've just
singed my eyebrows" face.
Dan: Quite some eyebrows
to singe as well.
More fuel in them
than in the oil.
Gav: New profile pic?
( both laugh )
I really enjoyed that episode.
We got some good footage.
- It was very informative.
- Oh, totally, yeah.
Also, don't try
the experiment at home.
- It's quite dangerous.
- That it is.
Hopefully,
you enjoyed that episode.
Feel free to subscribe
to the Slow Mo Guys,
and make sure
you check out other episodes
from "Planet Slow Mo."
- What?
- Nothing.